I received a email from the Department
of Health with a link to the CDC
advising me as a physician that they
were going to adjust the way death
certificates were completed what did a
just death certificates mean they said
in this document if you think that
covid-19 was a contributing condition
you can put it down as a cause of death
and I said no
there's a box too on a death certificate
called contributing conditions that's
where you put contributing conditions if
it's emphysema if it's asthma
influenza we put it in the contributing
conditions box we were being told with
this disease we could put it as a cause
of death